the wife of late Senator John McCain
describes our current political
discourse as awful
sandy McCain still is a fervent
political observer and says she's
hopeful about the future of the
Republican Party
we spoke to mrs. McCain yesterday in
Washington for an interview only on CBS
this morning
she addressed her husband's legacy and
whether his children will follow in his
path
what's the quintessential John McCain
that that you would want people to keep
in their head I would want people to
remember his his honor his courage
obviously his dignity and his ability to
use humor in all of this humor is a
great leveler and boy he could he could
do he was the best at that I thought he
lived every day to its fullest he
enjoyed it he enjoyed the fight he
taught me that I mean he taught me how
to not just not how to live a life that
to respect a life and enjoy it and enjoy
what you're doing if you don't enjoy it
then what's the purpose he often talked
about falling in love with his country
when he was deprived of its company and
now that you've been deprived of his
company he is there an energy do you
hear him in your head saying giving you
guidance for how to deal with this
period
well I catch myself asking in everything
I do I think gosh what would John do you
know what what would he think or what
would he tell me to do was there a
particular instance where you thought
this is exactly what he would say oh
yeah oh my gosh oh yeah I find
especially in this political climate now
I find myself saying things I know that
he would have not only said or thought
about which is kind of fun
what do you think he would say about
kind of where things are now I think
he'd say a lot of things I I think he's
I think he would be terribly frustrated
you know he was the one that was the
kind of conscience of the Senate and
we've lost his voice and and
consequently I saw an elective process
this year unlike anything I've ever seen
and I think many people would say that
it was abominable he would have he would
have I know quite frankly would have
said enough this is this is not only
wrong but it's bad for the guy
he had you talk about the respect and
dignity which existed after
extraordinary fights he had some tough
fights with George Bush with Barack
Obama John always said a fight nut joint
is a fight not enjoyed I think many of
our leaders fail to remember nowadays
that disagreement is part of the process
disagreement is but not distrust listen
we're all Americans we're all you know
here for the same reason and trust as
part of this trust in knowing that
people are there for the right reasons
and they are I believe in the process
and I know John did you've spoken out at
various times in politics that not often
but occasionally yes I've got myself in
trouble before but enjoying the fight
the way senator would have it how does
that role change for you now well it you
know I'm I am not an elected official
but I do have the right to my own
opinion one thing John said said to me
is that you you stay high you stay high
on these things and and I agree I agree
after the Senators death a lot of people
thought well Cindy McCain she should
take the seat did you ever talk about
that with the senator no did anybody
ever reproach you and did you ever think
about it serious I didn't approach from
a bunch of different directions yes I
have my job right now is to make sure my
family's okay and make sure that we are
we're moving on in the right direction
so if you're not gonna run for office
there's mega in this jack did any of
them have political aspirations so I
think we'll see one possibly to do it
there are two I know that won't but
there's two there that I think well you
want to fill that ballot out for us but
I think you know they're all they've all
grown up in politics it's hard not to
you either catch the bugger you don't
you you have launched a lot of politics
and I've had a front-row seat to history
you've done an amazing ride yeah
and you've seen it get you've seen some
pretty tough politics the level of
discourse is
is really awful and so when I see see
the differences and the hatred that's
going on right now it's it's hard do you
feel like you still have a home in the
Republican Party yes I and John have
said the same thing we will always be
Republicans I think the party itself
will you know it's as you know politics
is very cyclical and we both believed
and talked about it after so that we
believe the pendulum has swung and it
will swing back I think will come back I
think will come back to the kind of
party that we've always been and that's
a party of Abraham Lincoln that's who we
are he asked that every year on his
birthday August 29th that we have a big
party recently mrs. McCain returned home
to their family ranch in Arizona for the
first time and that was hard it was hard
because it was so much everything there
so much him that that I had to really
kind of take a breath and and work
through it a bit I did what he had said
to do and it was very helpful actually I
you know he used to hit a certain drink
that he liked I know you know this it
was vodka on ice with an onion in it and
so come come his he called it the
bewitching hour and the most beautiful
time of the day so that time of the day
the first day I made one of those rings
I don't drink that but I made one of
those drinks and put it out took a
picture of it well you know with the
lawn behind and then put it up on
Instagram and said you know here's
here's to you Johnny
here we are that's beautiful John oh
yeah and she the senator had a favorite
playlist that they played while he was
while he was sick and she says she's
been listening to that again too and so
the whole family is is learning to move
on you know what we've lost in this
culture of outrage is something that she
talked about you know that disagreement
is part of the process but not distrust
it's okay to disagree forcefully with
people that's part of the project
enjoyed it right the whole process was
set up for that absolutely and I have to
say when was the last time you listened
to someone who's been involved in
politics that you could say I could keep
listening to them for a long
I could have heard another ten minutes
when she's so reasoned she's had such a
front-row seat to history I mean I want
to hear more from Cindy McCain me too so
far this week it's been Michelle Obama
and Cindy McCain class acts that you
want to keep thinking keep talking keep
talking different parties and more of
them well if you want to hear more on
today's CBS's firing progress that's an
ally you from is O'Donnell you can hear
our full interview with Cindy McCain our
podcasts are available on Apple's
podcast app or wherever you like to
download your podcasts yet another
reason to listen to our podcast there
you go